so this is your final project for the
class and judging by the looks of it
your resume should be just about done
great job but before we can let you off
the hook
remember that we've learned quite a bit
about objects and the way that they can
encapsulate information and related
functions this is a two-part final
project in the first part take the
display functions that you wrote and
encapsulate them within their respective
display work and education objects the
second part of this project is to make
the page your own you can add whatever
you want to show how truly awesome you
are in the instructors notes we've added
links to a couple of cool JavaScript
libraries to do interactive graphics and
charts right there are thousands of
awesome JavaScript libraries out there
and most of them are really simple to
include in your project go the extra
mile and make your project really stand
out by taking advantage of any one of
them good luck